[Music]
thank you my thing is much and thank you
for all of you to be here on a Saturday
morning to hear about a what I have to
say today so yes chef you mentioned that
we'll tell you about a privacy and
blockchains and specifically I want to
tell you about how a specifically to
graphic construct zero knowledge proof
are useful to achieve privacy and
blockchains so in order to a so motivate
so I would like to first motivate the
problem and then explain why there is a
anything to do in a sense that why is
there a problem to solve what's the
technical difficulty so as a motivating
example let me just remind you that in
the Bitcoin blockchain the way that
transactions you can absolutely think
about the transactions as basically
containing a signed messages that spell
out where the payment is coming from how
much is being paid and where it goes
okay together with the signature
authorizes the payment m and you know i
think i've been talking about so privacy
and abductions now for several years and
in the past I really had to sort of make
a case for why putting a payment in the
clear and in the blockchain should worry
you now I hear it sort of some people
are laughing is so let's let's try to go
through and understand why we should
worry about putting payments in the
clear in the blockchain okay
so first it should be clear that payment
history reveals a lot of information
right so it can reveal a medical
information so an insurance company
could use a sort of a history of your
payments to sort of increase your
premiums so for example if you you know
pay an oncologist then maybe you're sick
with cancer a or even denied coverage a
also your history of payments actually
reveal your kind of location so there's
also question of you know personal
safety so if you're buying coffee in a
particular city probably you're there
right yeah and also it contains a wealth
of private information if you're running
a business right and not by chance this
is one of the reasons that the banking
industry industry is highly regulated so
they are managing they see all of your a
private in financial information and
store it on their servers and they have
to be careful with that and if they mess
it up they will be fined very dearly by
the government okay so that's why it is
highly regulated so now in Beacon I was
likely being unfair that you don't
actually post your payments together
with your first and last name of when
you send the payment you actually have
an address okay so it's just a string
it's a cryptographic public key and you
spell out the cryptographic public key
that sends the payment and the
cryptographic public key that is
supposed to receive the payment okay so
it's not quite names those are just
addresses and indeed this is a kind of
the a perspective or rather the reason
for why now ten years ago when Bitcoin
started it was regarded as an anonymous
payment system right there's no names
there's just this payments be sent
between cryptographic public keys yeah
they're just addresses but first and
foremost they are known with everybody
you interact with right so if you sort
of add up our point of sale at the very
least you know the address of the
merchant that you're interacting with I
mean that's the point right you're
getting something in return for the
payment and also in many realistic
scenarios the merchants themselves gets
to learn a the payment that the or the
tying the fact that you are sending a
payment because there
some good or like in some service in
return right after all in many cases you
want to use payments to achieve some
outcome in physical world right so at
some point there is some connection
between addresses and physical
identities and these addresses are just
sitting out there on the blockchain you
can actually just point your browser to
and like read it okay and it can be
really analyzed by a value and one way
you can conceptualize this information
that is sitting on the blockchain it you
can think about it as a transaction
graph that over time so you have this
cash flow that moves between different
addresses right and depending on what
happens with payments they will have
different structures in other way to say
that is that this transaction graph
carries information about through
payments right there has been several
academic studies that say that a it's
actually not that hard to take this
transaction graph correlated with some
side information and basically turn this
a virtual cryptographic keys into names
of actuals or physical people okay and
let me just highlight you might be
thinking wait isn't the anonymizing good
so for example you might have read that
the FBI several years ago used
what you could call blockchain forensics
which is basically reading very
carefully what's in the blockchain to
actually track down people that were
running a markets for illicit goods like
drugs and weapons and gonna figure out
who they are and you know bring them to
justice
okay in fact there are private companies
are there for example chain alysus and
elliptic that provides services to third
parties to a sort of kind of provide
white lists or black lists of addresses
so these companies might spend time
trying to understand the blockchain and
say look this address has been involved
in what are likely illicit activities so
maybe you know one accept payments from
this address okay so it's kind of trying
to provide de-risking services for
merchants all right
yeah but fractionalize is also dangerous
so here's for example the first page of
a court case this was actually two years
ago where the in the IRS sent a subpoena
to coinbase coinbase is the largest
crypto currency exchange in the United
States it has over 20 million customers
and the IRS a asked coinbase to reveal
the identities and the corresponding
cryptographic keys for going basis
customers okay why because the IRS was
had this S or antiquated the opinion
that everybody does doing
cryptocurrencies is also a involved in
illicit activities so cumbias went to
court and arguing that this is what's
called so John Doe summons where there
was no no credible case that the IRS
could make that every single of the
customers of coinbase would be involved
in illicit activities and tried to argue
that look please tell me which customers
so you think might be involved I'll give
you those addresses right that we more a
reasonable thing to do when again
happened some some sort of M so there
was a called proceedings in the end the
only allowed 10,000 account holders to
be handed over to the government
okay and my opinion is that a police is
still a large number and actually what's
a very worrisome here is that of these
10,000 people owe you let's say even
some of them maybe they were involved in
some illicit activities okay but I say
that it may be the answer to those
crimes at this point but now the
government actually has the
cryptographic keys of these people I can
actually track them into the future
indefinitely okay so this power of
tracking on the blockchain is incredibly
a sort of
really out of control okay sort of it's
a piece of information as is sitting out
there and sort of the amount of
information that you know know about the
transaction graph all increases
monotonically with time and the more and
more you kind of generalize the more it
helps you generalize other addresses
okay and there's no way to kind of
escape the minimization so as basically
keep the currency moves away from first
movers and maybe also criminals into the
mainstream okay having a sort of private
information sitting out there merely in
the form of cryptographic keys is very
problematic because the moment somebody
gets a hold of your cryptographic key
suddenly can look at your past and
future sort of working from there so
privacy actually a big problem in this
respect worry if you're free to stop any
of questions the question is so far
question okay so right now you have
presumably a bank alright where you hold
your money
and the bank knows who you are and knows
exactly what you're doing but it's only
the bank that knows okay yeah well and
you know whoever they have business
relationships the Waypoint is not it's
not arbitrary people anywhere so right
now in the in the case of Bitcoin like
you could pull out your laptop point
your browser to the any sort of so
called the blockchain explorers and
anybody can you know even download to
there actually there are open source
tools you can download the developer
academics to conduct a blockchain
analysis and anybody can actually learn
information about you whereas right now
it's only the bank and whatever you know
third-party relationships it have so
it's very different this respect so one
of my a it yeah they can find your
contracted transactions and the sort of
one of my colleagues Ian Myers has a
I think a lovely quote that says bitcoin
is like Twitter for your bank account so
it's um every event is kind of publicly
broadcast surely without identities but
you know it soon enough it will be
attached to it
great point and of course you know we're
all fine with revealing our financial
identities to you know a particular
third party the bank who must follow the
law must throw manage our private
information according to some a well
specified the regulations and so on okay
so
one can of course try to have whiskey
history you know just use a new address
for each payment maybe we'll all get
together and snow mix our money and
basically sort of use traditional money
laundering techniques to protect our own
privacy seems harder to analyze but the
point is that is not really an effective
mitigation okay so of course it will
make it harder maybe for a human to
eyeball what's happening but you know
algorithms are very good at extracting
back patterns so it's the moment you
apply some minimal sort of heuristics
and machine learning to this type of
information you know it would be
defeated and really the problem here is
that fundamentally in Bitcoin and more
generally any system where you're
recording your transaction details in a
clear text this history is publicly
stored forever and the methods of
analysis only get better okay and then
the more successful system is the more
it interacts with the physical world and
the more you can correlate information
gained on you mais okay so it's really
like a problem okay separately if you
actually don't care about privacy some
people actually really don't and I
understand why but in their economic
motivations to care about what you store
in a blockchain
and it has to do with something called
fungibility the point is that at least
the way that we set up a lot of the
economies set up today is that we have
things like cash or currencies and the
point is that I can pay you in any now
can pull out of my wallet you know
different types of bills and as long as
they add up to the correct amount I can
just pay with those and you shouldn't
care exactly which bills I pull out of
my pocket however you know bitcoin is
not fungible because misses you can see
for every sort of payment that I send
you you can see the pedigree you can see
the history of what led to that
particular coin that now is about to
make its journey to you and you may have
some opinions about whether you like or
not the history of this particular coin
so to some extent the value of a coin is
ill-defined
because different people may value the
same coin differently simply because
they might disagree on whether they like
or not like is history
the same person could value different
coins differently and more generally
coins that have shorter history are more
valuable because they're less likely to
sort of have opinions people sort of
over value or undervalued them and
actually it's so bad that today already
a sort of fresh bitcoins are more
valuable than all the bitcoins precise
just because of this reason okay and
there are also third-party services that
will use blockchain analysis tools to
validate whether coins have a good
history and those are come at a premium
okay so now the notion of value is some
extent centralized okay and because it's
ill-defined
so like if you want to buy like a newly
minted coin you know they will sell it
to you at a premium at a higher price
because if I have another coin that has
a longer history then you your ability
to spend it is impaired so when you're
trying to buy I don't know you know the
famous example of buying pizza with
Bitcoin right you might be charged more
bitcoins if you're a plan to use it
because with longer history because then
the merchant has the liability of having
sort of all bitcoins that in the future
may be revealed to be involved in
illicit activities anyway and therefore
they might lose part of their value so
it's kind of a risk mitigation okay so
no cash of course we have serial numbers
and so they are uniquely identified it's
not like they're literally fungible in
down to the you know last point but the
point is that we don't know their
history that's a feature okay so this is
like completely Sibelius put has nothing
to do with privacy it's just on economic
terms what does it mean for something to
be fungible some of privacy you know
comes in and effects it okay I think
there is some problem to solve and if
it's open if it's so important why why
isn't it solved so here is what we have
and you know at some point you know I
receive some money later on and want to
spend it right and when I spend it other
people
need to check that I have this money to
spend how do people know it because they
can go back in history and check that it
received it in the in the interim I
didn't spend it therefore I have it okay
so you might wonder okay so whatever we
have some private information sort of
the the usually the quick solution is to
just encrypting the relevant a sensitive
information and be done with it why
don't you just encrypt the payment
details and then post them on the
blockchain so here how it would look
like we have transactions that are not
encrypted okay so instead of having the
keep that got a key of the sender get
the galaxy key of the receiver and the
amount all these pieces are encrypted
and then post it on the blockchain
what's the problem then I can encrypt
under you know the the sender's public
key for example so that they can decrypt
but then there's not a problem yes right
so I can't tell anymore whether
particular payment is valid or not also
somehow like privacy and integrity are
thoughts because why does we can achieve
a payment system because it achieves
this notion of consensus so we can agree
on the events that happened so I cannot
double spend because when I do double
spend there is a sort of undeniable
trace that I did so very explicitly so
in clear text in the blockchain okay
somehow the fact that the information is
literally there is important for
currency to mean anything okay as this
kind of unit these tokens that can be
sort of there is their digital but
they're kind of at any moment in time
they're owned by only one person right
don't be double spent em so yeah it's
just not clear what to do
person right because let's take this
particular example so Bob wants to pay
Eve 3 why would she be why the can he do
that well because at some point he
received 3 and I can go and check that
this transaction didn't involve Bob
spending 3 this one didn't this one
didn't this one didn't
if I did it this way I would see a bunch
of junk and creep the junk all right I
encrypt the information that looks like
junk and I can't decide really when I
decrypt this information because was
sent to me whether I I receive a payment
that is valid or what in the meantime it
was spent somewhere else ok so what I
want to do in the I guess think I mean
20 minutes is I wanna tell you how one
resolves this tension ok so if you hear
is that we're gonna be using some how is
your knowledge proofs and by now today
there is a number of protocols that you
could go about to try to solve this
problem the one I will explain today is
called a zero cash protocol something
that I worked on with my colleagues and
so when I was a student back at MIT and
this is a cryptographic protocol that
achieves a ledger base currency there is
privacy-preserving
by the way when I say let your base it
doesn't really matter whether it's based
on a proof of work on a proof steak or
Algar and all I'm really using is the
fact there is some ledger somewhere so
what I'm discussing is for the most part
orthogonal to the way that we achieve
agreement on the sequence of events on
the blockchain and by piracy presenting
I mean that we'll be able anybody will
be able to post payment transactions
that contains something in them that on
the one hand they can be validated for
you know being good payments but at the
same time they probably hide the payment
send the receiver and amount okay which
are in this case the pieces of
information I was trying to hide a as a
bonus it actually happens that this
cryptographic solution is that efficient
and a you know these transactions take
just a few seconds to produce they're
very small and a
easy to verify so let's try to think of
the very basic intuition at high level
what it is I'm trying to do so
intuitively we are going to encrypt a it
information I'm at the end of the day
like we can't put information there
because when we put it than we have lost
so we can't put it there so let's say
that we encrypted now the thing that was
missing was a way for third parties not
involved in a particular transaction to
establish whether that payment was valid
or not notice that establishing whether
payment is valid or not a method to do
that is to look at the payment details
but as a third party you don't actually
care about the payment details you just
care about validating the payment so
what we're going to do is we're going to
attach a proof of validity of the
payment okay to each transaction
okay so encrypted payments and prove
elite encrypted and clear payment
details prove ability so the way it
would look like is when Alice produces
her transaction she's going to say hey
I'm going to publish three cipher texts
they contain the encryptions of a sender
address a receiver address and a
transfer amount transfer amount well
over the amount transferred has now been
double spent and here's a cryptographic
proof that all of this is true okay now
for this to make sense we need to
understand what kind of cryptographic
proofs are we going to use here okay so
it's going to be some method that
convinces third parties of this
statement and then what exactly are we
proving in a sense that is just English
okay it's just a few sentences right but
at some point there's gonna be you know
some specific mathematical statement
about the payment that I need to prove
to others okay I want to tell you a
little bit about that so first there's
the what character terrific proof well
first has to be a proof what is the
proof mean it means that I ought to be
able to produce valid looking proofs for
true statements and I should not be able
to produce very looking proofs for
statements that are not true so for
example if I have indeed already spent
my money I should not be able to produce
transaction that spent that money again
and the proof is valid okay
a these are proofs I need to be able to
write down and including a block this
seems like why would you worry about it
we'll ask cryptographers we think all
the time about interactive proofs and so
in this case it's important I are able
to write it down and crucially
importance here the privacy property
will come from a notion called zero
knowledge that
Shafi and C be introduced many years ago
that is it will make sure that this
cryptography proof could can be
validated using I mean the Kaveri group
contains information that that on the
one hand allows for validating the
payment but does not reveal the payment
details otherwise here's a proof for
validating the payment I give you the
decryption key you did you decrypt the
ciphertext and you check it yourself
right so that's a valid way of providing
the proof right that's not what we're
going to do is maybe some indirect
method that still convinces you that
underlying plaintext satisfy some nice
property yet the way that I'm convincing
you has this Z knowledge property that
doesn't leak information about the plain
text underneath there are other
properties and the only reason why I'm
mentioning them is for in this talk is
that you may have heard of this acronym
ZK snark in fact we had three days of
workshops at the Berkeley marina on this
primitive that's where these things come
from but for today for this talk the
only thing that matters really is just
this zero knowledge property I could
spend an entire talk and more about this
primitive but when I focus on today is
how we use it okay I'm gonna tell you
about given such a magical object about
zero knowledge proof how to actually go
about producing privacy-preserving
payments I guess I'm going to take this
as a black box for now okay the
questions because we're not going to
talk about this proof again
how I can track everyone but Buddha who
do even and in practice there is
something like home base who is
collecting anyway see it's already one
it knows what is happening on the legend
they are able to the office get the
ledger an attacker can go any way to
coinbase steal the keys and learn
everything now well if we're going to
give the secret keys to the adversary
there's nothing I can do right so yeah
well at some point if I I have to
distinguish myself me honest person
against everybody else typically this is
a cryptography secret so I have to make
sure that I manage my own secrets
properly if I entrust coinbase with my
own secrets I am entrusting them with my
privacy and indeed my integrity so if
somebody enters their database and
steals a my secrets because I gave in to
coin based at this point there is no
logical difference between me and
adversary and in particular they can do
whatever I could so managing your own
secrets is difficult okay custody of
Secrets is really hard okay and as we go
forward with the blockchain technology
it is important as individual users and
as an industry to come up with best
practices for secrets in particular I
think one of the exciting developments
around a central centralized exchange is
this some of them are starting to
explore so-called noncustodial services
where they're still providing to you
marketplaces where you can exchange
tokens but you till it's still retain
custody of your own secrets okay
honestly most of our stuff is sort of
centralized my gmail is centralized my
Dropbox is centralized I mean this is
convenient and people do do that even if
I can't trace it here you know if I send
money to you I'll be off my whatsapp and
say oh did you get the money you know
whatever you know that have you seen it
on the blockchain like you know there
are there are going to be so many side
channels - okay there's different things
here so one is if you give your secrets
to corn-based Khan base you know will
track you fine but it's not the third
parties oh what if the attack chrome is
okay fine but you know that that's
equivalent to give me your secrets
somebody else but a point is that
short-term your secrets to somebody else
the blockchain itself doesn't contain
information so I understand that's kind
of the question in a sense that there is
not there's even even for integrity this
is a nothing with privacy by the way
we're discussing equally privacy and
adversary's spending your money without
your consent
so that's the convertible point - yes
receiver cannot know where he received
the money from let's say the receiver is
a coin use account which is fully
compromised and I'm still trying to
preserve my e it is possible to achieve
that you don't know where money comes
from I will not highlight that today
because you want to be in your accounts
I mean you can send a buddy they don't
know where it came from what I want to
say is that sort of I think this
discussion is more about custody rather
than privacy in a sense that both
authorizing your payments and your own
privacy is eventually rooted in some
secret that distinguishes you with from
everybody else right and you know
whoever controls you or you know that's
your right and what do you think about
the future of IRAs or all those US
government's the tax system in United
States is honor based and that's how it
is so you know you it is the
responsibility of reporting your tax
your financial dealings lies on you and
if you don't that you are in violation
of the law and you know whether the the
the government finds you're not that's
their problem that's sort of it
responsibility lies in here
another government problem right but it
already is so about you I'm not gonna
discuss tax considerations that these
particular considerations have little to
do with you know if you have a study
let's break this thing if you're if you
run you know like a an ice cream truck
you know in a suburban city and you make
your money and ice creams you know
report your you know so your cash
transactions their government a you know
your evaluation will all equally ice
cream tracks a really great business you
should if you know how many hungry kids
there
so what is what exactly the statement
we're going to prove with zero knowledge
okay so before we only had the aim it's
an English sentence okay so and this is
actually where the protocol design comes
up okay so I want to spend ten the
answer I spent ten minutes telling you
the first few steps of the protocol okay
how we go about setting apps and data
structures that are reasoning about the
blockchain and these are gonna be like
some data structures that can prove
things about okay so I'm going to do it
in a cryptographic fashion we're gonna
start with something that is completely
broken and makes no sense I'm gonna
patch it up piece by piece until we
achieve you know some some design
actually happy I think rather simple so
my view of the blockchain is gonna I'm
gonna so the template 0 I'm gonna have
several slides laid out in similar ways
so let me tell you kind of what the
template is I'm gonna always have the
blockchain at the top different colors
will denote different types of
transactions we're gonna have some
notion what coin means down on the Left
right now it's empty cuz we haven't
started so let's start so let's have a
very stupid notion of a coin it's just a
random number we let's call it a serial
number the way you create a coin is you
declare to the world here
I have created a coin with this number
the way you spend the coin is you
declare to the world I'm spending that
coin with this serial number okay it
could be confusing because it's almost
noon just you know it because I'm
starting with a very basic construction
as awesome almost has no problems I want
to say the one thing and what's gonna
happen is that the events is gonna have
you know somebody's gonna meet the coin
somebody else is gonna mean Terry coin
at some point somebody gonna spend it
and what's the important thing here I
want you to notice notice is that you
cannot spend a coin unless it was minted
at some point in the past okay some of
this serial number uniquely define this
coin and you cannot crucial you cannot
double spend because we try to Brok us
twice spend event with the same serial
number in this
and we'll tell you know OS pretty much
the only good thing in this design a
first kind of by design spend is
linkable to the mint okay that's how you
see that double spent of anybody can
spend in fact I sent a mint transaction
and somebody else can spend it for me
cuz they just saw the serial number okay
in particular there are no secrets here
so there's no cryptography but why don't
you just to think in this notion of
serial number case your number uniquely
tied to a coin let's improve on this now
we'll have a different coin the serial
number okay it's going to be secret and
we're going to commit to it to create a
so-called coin commitment so now when I
create the coin I only publish the coin
commitment I'm saying hey world I have
created a coin with some serial number
and I'm not telling you right now what
it is later when I spend it I'm telling
you by the way here the serial number
with the commitment randomness that
corresponds to the commitment that I had
before so the way now things look like
is this right now when I see a spent
transaction here I can check that it
corresponds oh it doesn't correspond to
this one oh but it looks to this it
corresponds to this one so it's fine
I can spend it I can expand it again
because the same cell number would show
up
so cannot double spend but yes I have to
check all your numbers that haven't
shown up both in the previous one it's
not necessary can be yeah the crucial
thing that's happened here is that
because I'm not revealing the serial
number at minting you cannot spend my
coin okay because you don't know the
serial number I'm only telling you the
coin commitment and a commitment you
know hides information okay
so what's bad is that we we set out to
prevent linking we're still things are
linkable okay so we have to kind of go
beyond this so here is where we're gonna
start using a zero knowledge proof for
doing something basic the data structure
for the coin has not changed it
continues to be a commitment to a random
serial number minting also hasn't
changed I publish a commitment to the
coin when I want to minted by the way
I'm assuming that there is some monetary
policy around it why can you mean the
coin what probably because you know
you're consuming some other resources
somewhere else so there is some way to
control a when you can mint right so
you're kind of converting some other
resource into this one now spending I'm
going to reveal the serial number like
before but instead of giving you the
full information about my commitment
like they're creating information that
then would tell you which commitment I
was referring to in the past I am going
to produce a synonym I'm gonna press a
proof there is your knowledge that
attests to two things first there exists
the commitment in the list of prior
commitments that corresponds to the
serial number the revealing right now
okay so I'm saying here's here's the
proof and here's the serial number and
I'm telling you I'm proving to you in
zero knowledge that I know some
commitment that is in the list of all
your numbers of the Koken commitment
that appeared so far and one of them are
not only which one is such that I can
put in some random string and I will get
that commitment for the serial number
that I'm revealing
okay it's some sort of set membership
and proving to you that the
coin whose helo number and revealing
belongs to the set of all coin
commitments of five don't are not
telling you which so what's good here is
that we still cannot spend because were
revealing still numbers people still
cannot spend my coins because I have the
secrets and other people don't
but I'll crucially spend them in Turin
linkable okay that's very important
whenever I see a spent all I see is just
some random number and a proof that
tells me that I somebody has spent some
coin that was created in the past
comfortably this I only have you know
two more slides and then we're gonna fix
a few more things but you know this is
the first place we're using as you know
much proof is it clear yes if I in the
previous slide because I was revealing
just are what you can do together with
the serial number is you compute forward
the commitment and you get the actual
con commitment you just literally
check-in the list
commitment is a commitment because you
cannot change what's inside it right so
if you could then we had up we would
have had a problem even before you can
think about ours random and it's
important it is random but what's more
important is that the serial number is a
that would not be a commitment because
if you could do that then it would
violate sort of I didn't really linger
too much on commitment but so you think
of commitment as you know you put some
information in a box and you open the
box later you got change information in
the meantime
with this example one time spends are
not linkable to anything but when you
really wanted is the spend itself no
skis perhaps that's what we are going to
do next what was that was that your
question yeah so right now we don't have
a payment system of any sort we're just
playing with tokens we're putting them
in anonymity pool we're pulling them out
later and it's a nice game but we're not
really cheating anything so right now in
particular notice that there is no
notion of address right now okay so to
start transacting we need to introduce
notions of address so all right let me
just I have one before the the address
slide which is next and I have the value
slide so let me introduce values
hopefully that will make you is that
there's nothing much is happening here
I'm introducing a value so when you coin
when you mint when you procreate a coin
commitment it has a value tied to it
okay and when you're minting you tell
the world which value how much value
your minting because it again is coming
from some other resource when you're
spending you prove the same thing you
prove that the coin commitment was a
list of prior commitments you prove that
everything you have in mind is well
formed and that's how it works
comfortable I've just added
denominations okay
I split in two slides because it's
easier to think about okay so we're only
really really hiding the sender right
now if you're trying to send money to
the receiver you pull it out with an
immunity pool and then you actually have
to send it you know to the receiver so
how are we gonna do that so now we're
going to reduce the notion of payment
address and this is the other second
idea of this protocol how we're gonna
tie coins with identities so we are
going to have a public key committed to
in the coin commitment and then there's
another quantity your row we call it the
serial number seed it's used to produce
the serial number keyed on a secret key
so you have some hash function that
hashes together your seal number seed
and the secret key to produce the serial
number okay and the way that and the
public key and secret key pair is
related in some way this really matter
how its relate there is just some public
and secret key pair the new thing that
happened is that coin commitment is
owned by a particular public key and a
steel number depends on the secret key
this is an important asymmetry we're
gonna see it now okay so as before I
mean like before when I spend I say that
I know all the secret information about
the student number that I'm revealing
the commitment is in the prior list all
the things that I'm talking about this
data structure are correct and now I
have to prove that a serial number
before it was it was appearing at just
here right now I'm moving the serial
number here I'm making depend on the
secret key okay why would that be the
case
hey I'm still not paying anybody I'm
just introducing data structure does
anybody have an intuition for why the
the serial number should depend on the
secret key not the public here
intuitively I want to try to separate
when I pay somebody I'm gonna have to
create their coins right and I shouldn't
be able to predict when they spend their
own coins okay so I haven't really used
addresses here so here's the last slide
direct payments so this is the this is
the protocol okay so when I spend I
don't want to just create I don't just
want to burn my coin I want to create
another coin as the same time as I burn
my own coin okay and the proof is not
gonna say oh I burned my coin and I
could do though could do that because I
never burned it before through burning
it I have released some value that I can
imbue another coin with okay and that's
I'm going to use your public key I'm
going to create a new coin under your
name okay and then because the serial
number of this other coin depends on
your secret key I don't know when you're
gonna spend it okay so so it's just the
last slide I'm gonna go through it very
slowly and this is just basically the
key idea of how you get direct payments
I'm going to provide as you knowledge
proof that says I know a bunch of
Secrets which secrets well first I need
to talk about secrets from my coin the
coin a I know my coin commitment in the
past three days ago it has a certain
value which now I'm hiding even a bunch
of stuff related to the coin commitment
and then my own public key in my own
secret key here's what I'm proving about
my coin I've minted it it's well formed
I actually own it have to prove that I
own it by the way right notice here I'm
saying that I have the secret key for
the public key that is inside the coin
that I'm talking about okay and
revealing the serial number correctly I
also have to prove that I know
information about a new coin that I'm
creating it has a coin commitment which
by the way I'm revealing right now a
value that I'm also not revealing and
you know I'm creating I need to prove to
you that I'm creating it in a
well-formed way
and last but not least the value is the
same okay so in this way when you see
this transaction you know that all these
things happen in my head okay
I'm certifying it to you using this
proof okay so I think all I really
wanted today was just to get to this
slide because the main idea and what I
wanted to him to show you is that we had
an initial intuition which was I'm gonna
use the knowledge proof that I published
all these ciphertexts and underneath the
cipher text there is a valid payment
what we did from that high level
intuition to here is we turn that into
specific data structures or statements
about secrets okay that are sort of set
up so that we have this notion of a coin
and we're burning coins and credit coins
preserving value in between okay and
each time that now you mean and you
spend they maintain you spend when you
see a spend that you have no idea what's
going on you're juicing some random
value okay for a commitment for some new
coin you have no idea information about
it and all you know it's that value was
preserved it's all but that's like a
coin to another coin can I do two coins
to two coins short is a generalization
of that so you can split coins you can
merge coins you asking Brazil numbers
okay a what you can do is that I didn't
put here is you can also prove that the
serial number that you're revealing is
not in the list of all serial numbers
you could do that as well in practice
this is actually not what you do anyways
because the list of serial numbers
you're just
you can index it and you can just a
quickly check whether it appears that or
not
but from a surgical perspective is
totally reasonable to say let me let the
zero knowledge proof not only reason
about the list of all coin commitments
with an inclusion statement but the list
of all serial number is an exclusion
statement
no no but manure just you have the list
of all private coins now you're spending
some other one all you have to check is
that it's not there and so I provided
that you're not double spending exactly
there's not equality exactly yes but you
can put it in yes and in from a privacy
perspective is fine because what are all
these things all the probably other
coins that were spent in the past with
some serial number now you get some
other serial number you add it in and
you make sure it wasn't their size the
size of the pollution exclusion Merkle
trees works you can set up Merkle trees
with non exclusion proofs so I haven't
talked about the synthetics here so you
don't actually talk about entire list
use Merkle trees to come to kind of have
a logarithmic dependence it's something
I'm gonna stop here and maybe take any
questions but I just wanted to
communicate that they occurred years ago
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know horrible so good question so
there are two levels at which you can
try to think the question was a what is
post quantum about this protocol so when
you think about the protocol there are
two layers at which you can try to think
about a quantum adversary trying to
break why is the building blocks
themselves is the commitment scheme post
quantum secure to begin with because if
it's not then never mind what they were
doing with the product separately you
can say well it's assumed that each of
the building blocks the commitment
scheme does you knowledge prove the
pseudonym functions are post quantum
securing on their own now I combine them
in a particular protocol do you have a
reduction that is secure against quantum
adversary's now let me answer the first
question so in terms of concrete
practical primitives today it's a bit of
a mixed bag some of the some of the
primitives that we are using for
examples to random functions are
possibly post quantum because they're
just things like sha-256 other things
like zero nagy proofs they're currently
based on the script logarithm on the
harness with script logarithms so that
would not be now you could drop in
replace some 0h proof threes post
quantum as for the protocol itself I
haven't tried to do the analysis it's an
interesting question to say give me a
post quand tu n PRF post quantum
commitments quinoa blah can you get to
postponed to a payment probe I think
it's a good question I don't see a
priori what could go wrong but quantum
is weird and and so there are many
settings were sort of you don't have a
direct port of reductions
okay so break
[Applause]